you know it's funny that Conan became
your friend but not funny in the sense
that he wrote for Saturday Night Live
and I couldn't understand the connection
yeah but you too with the famous Story
Goes that when I guess Letterman was
leaving his slot they offered it to you
and at the time at the time you said no
[ __ ] way I don't want to do late
night television I don't know if I can
film five hours well yeah there's more
or that I mean they gave me a a contract
with no obligation because Brad gray is
a genius at negotiating right they gave
me a million dollars just to say I was
considering it I go are you sure I know
he goes they got to make an announcement
so I was kind of torture that year
because I I did I was thought oh that
might be really fun I I had a baby and a
two-year-old and I had all this stuff
flying at me almost got too hot for my
own good I was on covering Rolling Stone
twice I got the Emmy it was after
Wayne's World Wayne's World it exploded
the bush Perot thing so it was way way
too much for me to process and Warren
Littlefield which I could thank him now
publicly gave me a gift for are
considered which was the meet the
Beatles album autographed by all four
Beatles wow which I understand is now
worth about two hundred thousand dollars
wow so I did think of it for a year and
during that time I was writing a movie
with Conan and Robert Smiggle and Kevin
Neal and Hans and Franz The girlyman
Dilemma what a great team of people I
know to be a really funny script really
funny were you disappointed they never
made that movie The Hans from France
movie you know I this other part of my
life was so obscure and bizarre but as
it goes we did make Arnold
Schwarzenegger a key piece of it yes and
we did things like his how like one of
the funny things in the movie like we go
to come on in fellas because it's Hans
and fronds seeking Arnold real Arnold
would have been in it yeah the real
Lauren we go into like a war room you
know when they push the things around
and he goes yeah Bruce Willis is doing
action adventure at Walnut Brothers I'll
block its only with a Kazan movie and
you know his doors were like two giant
buttocks that just opened and we were
going to be water skiing behind himself
it was really brilliantly written and um
but I didn't understand movie stars then
you know Arnold was sincerely interested
but he had 29 movies yeah so once he
fell out of it at the bottom kind of
fell is that the true story because the
story that I had always heard was that
two Saturday Night Live type movies
based on sketches the uh Al Frank and
Stewart Smalley one yes and the pat
movie yeah had kind of Tanked and that
uh Arnold's Last Action Hero hadn't done
that well at the box office so all of a
sudden it was like the Hans and Franz
movie got shelved which sucked for you
because you'd put in all this time
trying to develop it I think
um that's probably all true but I think
that they would have sort of we could
have Rewritten it and kind of lowered
the budget and made it right you know
right but it didn't happen so you know
you have all these decisions to make and
on top of that at least you say NBC
gives you a million bucks to like to
think about think about replacing yeah
at 12 30 at night yes and it was a
torturous decision you know when you
watch Jimmy Fallon doing it yes and he's
kind of figured out the way a Saturday
Night Live alumni should do yes now do
you look at it and say oh you know maybe
I could have done some sketches I could
have had some light patter yeah you know
like now do you get that you could have
done that and been really good at it I
think I would have been fine and the
main reason you know after the fact you
know why you'd be fine because the three
people over my shoulders would have been
Robert Smigel wow Conan O'Brien and
Louis C.K right so you could not fail
with that Brain Trust so I I I feel like
I would have been fine with it I just
with my personality at the time I wasn't
sure
um I thought maybe that was a single
man's game at the time just because of
the energy and Neurosis it would take to
be on TV every day but I assume you get
used to it you're saying Conan probably
would have been your writer yeah or
producer wow or producer boy that would
have been a good team huh yeah so you
know life's life short you know Smiggle
something huh Smiggle is the single
greatest if you have to pick one right
if you're going to start a writing staff
for sketch comedy you get Smiggle and if
you're going to start a a sketch comedy
true you get Hartman
foreign